[Music]
you know that one time where we got
obsessed with penises on the show
when did we stop getting being obsessed
many times animal penises i remember
that day i had to google them all
true what kind of animal i wasn't here
that day what's going on here
oh we were looking at snake dicks like
dolphins
wondered what animals though i'd never
think of any animals with dicks
except for dogs because we have dogs i
forgot which animal but
it has like a corkscrew dick it was a
horse i think
pig pig pig yeah snakes have two dicks
yeah two dicks it goes like this it's
weird what doesn't that
sounds painful it really does sound
fantastic but all right so
scientists have recently uh are
nearing a discovery of what dinosaur
genitals i actually know this i know
this i know there's one
[ __ ] thing about dick no no no not
just as a woman tell me if i'm wrong
because i just literally had a
conversation about this okay okay what
what did it look like
it's called a khalifa like a wiz khalifa
or like a uh
like a weenie khalifa it's like a vent
or something
it's like a window or a vent and so
the the the genital whatever it is the
vagina of the penis
and the anus and and the birthing canal
is all the same place that's disgusting
yes what am i right it's called bio
major
bio major major dino major dino major
dino dick major that's nasty yeah it's
called a cloaca
what i call a cleveland leaflet
it's just all one hole basically they
don't know
if it was gonna be like how uh birds
have it or have crocodiles have it or
whatever i don't know well the birds and
crocodiles actually have the same thing
it's they they also have
a cloaca but the way they have
how birds do it though cloaca they don't
actually have
penises like birds they don't have
penises they just have the cloaca
and what they do when they have sex is
they they the the male bird and the
female bird
both have clinicals i guess and they
they they do a colloquial kiss
they just kind of kiss that's it and in
that time they transferred fluids
from male to female and that's how the
the female bird gets pregnant so then
how do you know who's the male
female there's no penis in there and
that we know that about birds
and what we know about like say
crocodiles reptiles
crocodiles have penises kept inside the
cloaca
now the the confusion for dinosaurs is
that dinosaurs
there's some people think they're closer
to birds like in in jurassic park now
they're like velociraptors they could
have been
winged and rooster like rooster like
yeah so we didn't know
if it was more like birds or more like
reptiles modern day modern day reptiles
or modern day birds
but now thanks to a new fossil that's
been
discovered they're assuming
that say for example a tyrannosaurus rex
it would have had a gigantic
bendy ass penis like
long penises that just come out of the
cloaca yeah so like
like a snake yeah yeah because like
they're thinking like well you can't
exactly put a t-rex on top of another
t-rex with the
tails like they would have to like
somehow they're just too big and heavy
and
if they fell over like they're thinking
arms they can't even like get back up
like having no dick wouldn't be uh
possible for
say gigantic dinosaurs to have sex with
so they're
assuming now thanks to this new fossil
that
it's possibly a gigantic dildo dick that
comes out and it's bendy and
he just kind of hoes it into the female
wow it's crazy
and that's a dinosaur dick i like that
because reptiles
actually have dicks right reptiles have
dicks
the cup the conversation has because
they found a cloaca
they found a cloaka yeah the first
intact cloaca
yes and then there's like enough uh like
skin fibers and tissue or whatever
that's for them playing golf
also known as a khalifa according to
dante
but uh yeah it's crazy how it kind of
like
wraps it up quick like a superhero you
know what i'm saying
you know like a superhero that got like
no genitalia they're just like
that's all right yeah like reptiles you
can't even see it you can't even
pop it out when it's ready to go crazy
is that you they stick it in and then
the baby forms in an
egg so it's not even like the baby comes
out it's the egg comes out
so instead of getting pregnant it's like
the egg
fertilizer then burns the egg dude
listen to this so yesterday i was uh i
forgot where i heard this i think you
were with me but
uh there's this octopus called the
blanket octopus and it kind of resembles
a blanket
and when they mate so the females are
the ones that look like blankets and
then when they mate there's
uh another octopus i forgot what that
one's called but it's like the male one
yeah well it's the middle one
and it's like this big so if the blanket
octopus is like [ __ ] hundred times
bigger than it's like a little
yeah so what happens is when it's gonna
impregnate the female
it like one of its little tentacles gets
full of sperm and what he does
he goes inside of the blanket octopus
the female
and then he like dies yeah he gives her
the arm the the female one rips the arm
off them what
yeah so she puts it inside of her and
then she stores it there when she's
ready to have kids
but that dude's gone crazy gave his life
to his children how romantic and she's
like i'm not ready yet [ __ ] i'll
use it later because it's in the praying
match it's like that like he busts a nut
and he's like ah hungry
and then [ __ ] eats them i need energy
i need energy for this sperm down to
make my babies don't black widows kill
their
their partners too i think they hate you
too i mean
i'm not one of those that's sexism on
another yes that's females are ruthless
no i mean i think it's the way things
should be yeah depends on what society
we're in but you're right i missed i
mean it happens
it should have been that animal i'm glad
i'm a human because sex feels so good
for them it seems so painful
the good news baby you about to have
some sex bad news is
i'm gone that's it would it be worth it
well you don't die aversion
at least your ego is restored would you
guys
would you guys think it'd be worth it if
humans were like that
die for sex we wouldn't have a choice
right you have no choice because you
have a
primal urge yeah all animals yeah
like what please populate that we create
and repopulate your species so you're
going to want to do it
but what pleasure do these ins like
animals get
that do that for pleasure i think
they're doing it for sure
what did they get out of it right
because humans what we get we're wired
this way because like we get sex out of
it so that's why
we want to do it but then if we were
wired
but they want to repopulate that's our
primal right so like our primal
is being horny that's the primal thing
but their primal
is just what is it but why are you horny
though
are you horny too rock to repopulate
yeah so i want to be the same
not repopulate just populate right but
then so like these animals
they're wired to mate as well but
they're mating ritual and everything
else is different
but they're not positively reinforced
is what i'm saying i don't think they're
smart enough to even know about positive
or negative they're just programmed
i think that's it i don't think they
have self thought humans are also kind
of
psychologically wired to think about uh
death with sex right like there's like a
whole whole
idea that sex like when you climax you
orgasm
there's like this idea of death that
goes with it right doesn't it
like the same feeling right it's
supposed to be like your mental clarity
euphoria where it's
like yeah yeah where you are like you
almost
yeah there's like a death like you die
you die a little or something i've never
heard of this
orgasm and never associated it with
death
you're at the most vulnerable state like
something like that
i feel the most human within the first
10 seconds of coming
i go ah and i'm like wow i'm so
intelligent when i
don't feel so oh okay i'm going back to
reality
ah back i'm a stupid human how do i get
out of here
yeah i went from like aliens to like
this is how humans should be
to like okay i'm a low-life again that's
fine so there's a saying it's in french
le petite mort le petit and it is an
expression
it's called the little death yeah it's
an expression which means the brief loss
or weakening of consciousness
and in modern usage uh refers
specifically to the sensation of post
orgasm as likened to death the first
attested use with the meaning of orgasm
oh no
never mind it's just like making sure
this pussy's so good that [ __ ] put me to
sleep
put you to sleep you're like i'm dead
the friends call
orgasm yeah yeah the little best the
little death yeah
i think we're kind of wired to think of
like like i don't know like
i don't think it's like death death
romanticism there's some connection
though the universe says hey
this is somewhat kind of like death how
did they come up with that is what the
interesting
thing would be right because it's like
did someone experience like a near death
and then now they're tying the two so
then it feels the same
yeah like when you die it feels like
you're climaxing then i'm ready to go
oh yeah cause remember we were talking
about that netflix show the surviving
death one where
a lot of people in that show that have
had near-death experiences where they
actually like
clinically were dead like their body was
dead and then that they felt like a
euphoric
feeling of like warmth and love and
light and it was just all really calming
i die every night then it can refer to
the spiritual release that comes with
orgasm or to a short period of
melancholy
or transcendence as a result of the
expenditure of the life force
have you feeling the spirits it's that
light stretchy
[Laughter]
the chi leaves through my dick
let you try the tantric sass you know
the tantric sex where you don't come and
you just
orgasm for like hours which you orgasm
through uh
we're trying to learn this when we're
younger you've done it you've done it
before i don't think i was successful
the only time i knew about it was
because sting like open like publicly
sting was into it you bust nuts without
busting yeah there's like all their
chakras and then it's like about the
breath of fire
you know like you breathe the breath of
fire bart has breath of fire
you're about to come or you're you
you're having sex you bring the energy
and then you bring it up through all
your chakras to your crown you're not
having sex
it's like you're having sex you're
having sick eggs but you don't have sex
but instead of
coming physically you're like
spiritually
spiritually explode through your crown
shots die
i want to try it and having like uh an
orgasm that's like
a hundred ten times or whatever they say
and you you tried that
i've tried it i don't think i mean i i
did not succeed
you keep going through your your dick
chakra yeah
can we try it again it's just not
working like i need more practice i
gotta get it here but it keeps ending
down here
you gotta do that breath of fire bring
it up
as you're having sex you're just like on
each other
i don't even know if i was doing it
right
we had we were reading some books with
my brothers
and we had met some other guys with
these
comic guys i love it all a bunch of
dudes talking about something
are there any women involved there were
two twins and they had like
videos and we borrowed the videos and we
were like kundalini
sex it was like some old yoga i mean
and sting obviously was very popular
talking about at the time so we were
like
staying's doing this [ __ ] let's try it i
know i was like things are three like
we can have sex for seven
hours and have an orgasm that's like
10 times my dick will break it was a
good idea but i don't think it's like
full-on
thrusting i think it's like seven hours
[ __ ] meditation
conehead [ __ ] i don't know exactly
daytime sexy
that's like some [ __ ] avatar that's
tied to the [ __ ]
hair [ __ ] sex yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
the hair goes your hair to your tail
thing right i'm gonna need some red bull
for that kind of stuff i did see sting
in a restaurant one time with his wife
that we know his wife and there was like
another girl with them
were you like are you doing the triangle
asian girl and they were like but we
were all
it was like it's a cool l.a restaurant
we were almost vibing and
i don't know we're like looking it was
like something going of course
everybody in russia was like yeah they
own some old
tantric sting sex going on there while
they were eating their spaghetti
they weren't doing sex but they were
getting cozy with each other when you
thought the eyes rolling back
yeah they were like it was late too it
was like one of these like
were they eating for seven hours no then
but in our minds we were like they're
about to go back to the crib and have
that tantric sex
i know it but what were they eating
spaghetti i think there was spaghetti or
steak or something
table that's romantic